I'll watch whatever I watch all these
and I'm like these beautiful young women
Prime candidates for motherhood like and
where why are they not having kids what
is going on you know what the number one
like indicator I forgot what what the
stat is but it's basically like the
birth rate goes down when women go to
college so like women start having like
less children when they started going to
college and it's and and they also when
mate selection was more in the woman's
hands basically what happened when it
became more in the woman's hands yeah
because because like in the 20s that was
when women started to get their own
apartment so like before they would go
straight from the dad to the husband
and like then women like started to go
and get like the Roaring 20s right they
started getting their own apartment and
like they then had more control of their
mate selection and like when women have
more control of their mate selection
they go for a smaller and smaller
percentage of guys where it's like you
know I mean why would they keep the bad
boy away when they say like get that guy
away from my daughter because they like
the dad knew he's not gonna stick around
but women it's like we're just so stupid
when it comes to mate selection just
because you work not you personally but
work with emotions instead of yeah
instead of logic
yeah and and it's also like I don't
think we have a good grasp of like our
league like I think women often sleep
out of their league well that that
that's that's the factually true though
yeah like all of the uh scientific
research and and uh dating data yeah
show that women always go for the most
attractive men but they tend to be able
to because men have a wider range of
willingness about like women have a very
tight range of their willingness to
sleep and men have a very wide range so
what happens is it's something like what
like the bottom six percent of guys are
just like left out of it and then it's
mostly the top 20 of guys who are
sleeping with all of the women yeah well
and and the other thing they they'll
always say oh well dating apps aren't
real life or that's the number one way
people are meeting under 30. yeah true
dude those things are depression have
you ever used those things the dating
apps no not really yeah I started to do
it for market research because I was
building mines in the social app we're
like let's maybe do a Tinder thing and
then I got addicted to it I met a girl
on it and it was like just I'm like why
I'm judging these people by the way they
look it's the most superficial crap and
I felt sick depressed afterwards well I
mean it's honest I think most guys it
starts with looks you know what I'm
saying but it's like the sound of their
voice and the way they smell is a big
dude it's just go on and swipe right on
every single one because there's like
the the I was I was reading uh
data on how men and women use these apps
differently women go on dating apps and
then swipe right on guys they find
attractive and then get messages from
every single guy and then guys go on
there and swipe on every single girl
hoping one of them matches with them
right well think about it like women
swipe right five percent of the time
guys just like there's a video where
guys
swiping everything it's like between 40
and 60 depends on the time of day if
it's after one a.m it's probably gonna
be like 70 or 80 because I'm in a
desperate mode I'm not anymore but at
the time I was that was uh yeah you know
but it's an interesting because women
like pick non-monogamy in our 20s and
then pick monogamy in our 30s when you
think about it but that but that's
obvious you know why
like it's getting harder for the woman
as she gets older so now she's like I
need I need a guy who's not going to go
anywhere yeah but that but again like so
when you have a culture like ours where
the the sexual revolution has just
completely destroyed the relationship
between both sexes that seems to be what
tends to happen but like in most
traditional cultures that's not the case
right like people settle down early they
get married women are known for straying
less often than than men do and so this
is part of what I was emphasizing
earlier this is why and I believe Fulton
Sheen even said this like a society's
value can be measured by the value of
its women because the men are always
going to want to sleep around the
question is uh are women going to be the
gatekeeper and say well like no we're
not having sex unless we're married
unless you can provide a stable uh home
and family for myself and for our
children and you're actually going to
stick around
I guess there's a diminishing return to
raising Psychopaths like if you'd have a
lot of kids that were all horrible
humans that would be worse than having
very few kids that were phenomenal
humans but then there comes a point
where it's like population risk you
might lose the human population if you
don't have enough kids so it's better to
just churn them out but like I think
that in order like is it better or worse
in other societies where they didn't
have a sexual Revolution the thing is we
have well no Society has survived a
sexuality I think it's coming everywhere
I think like with social media like I
and I get messages from guys all over
the world saying okay like feminism is
coming and you have places that were
typically like more traditional like
India is a one percent divorce rate and
I get messages all the time like saying
that under 30 and I don't know the exact
stat but under 30 like the divorce rate
is rising because Western ideas are
going everywhere and in my opinion most
places I think like I think it's going I
don't want it to get bad like I don't
want it to get worse but if I had to
predict it I think like you will see
women getting more modern well you've
seen the psychological operations the
military's been they get like a 20 year
old like e-girl and then they have her
make an account where she's talking
about how great it is to be in the army
or the Navy or whatever to get Sims to
join yeah oh my goodness operations with
what Pearl's saying about how in
countries that were more traditional you
see an increase in these abnormal
lifestyle choices this is the one form
of colonization and imperialism that the
left is very very comfortable with
if we went into these countries and we
destroyed their temples or took their
gold the left would be very upset and
rightfully so but instead what we're
doing is exporting ideas that literally
destroy these people's families and it's
praised it's celebrated but I wonder if
you were able to pull because now we're
in the age of of revealment you know the
Revelation we're in we're in the the
apocalypse essentially we're seeing the
thoughts of people now that we didn't
used to see so yeah we're seeing the
misery of the unmarried but if we had
seen into the minds of people in 1938
would they be Miser just as miserable or
more because they were getting beat by
their husbands like Sean Connery check
this analysis that men were all just
beating their wives yeah like oh that's
a way of a propaganda that they did in
like the 40s I can't remember when they
did it there's this girl who like breaks
it down really well her name's Rachel
Wilson she wrote the book occult
feminism but the propaganda like it's
mainly propaganda this idea that like
men were beating their wives left and
right like they it's a wave of
propaganda that was like between the 40s
and the 60s
yeah well you obviously have always had
men who were bad people there have been
horrible human beings throughout all of
history and yes the man is the head of
the household so he's an authority and
sometimes people abuse their Authority
that doesn't mean you do away with
authority right that doesn't mean
Authority is illegitimate and so yeah
there have always been animals who beat
their wives the idea that that is
inherit to or inherent to the family
structure into male headship in the home
is a leftist lie well it's complete
nonsense inherent only to marriages
where you can't escape if the woman's
bound and no one's going to take her
word for it kind of thing well but if
you're in a traditional way so so
there's a couple ways to approach this
firstly if you're in a traditional
Community where people are near their
family and friends if you married my
sister and you're beating her or you
married my daughter and you're beating
her like people had large your families
she had a lot of brothers she had a dad
she had other men who were interested in
protecting her like there were very
serious social incentives to not be that
kind of person if you added in you to be
that kind of person the idea that men
were going ah we're in the patriarchy so
I'm okay if my sister's husband beats
her or my my daughter's husband beats
her sorry
yeah it's it's complete nonsense that is
that has always been one of the most
universally detested behaviors by men
nothing makes men angrier uh than woman
beaters other than maybe uh sexual
abusers and people who fantasize about
stopping villains and protecting women
and children it's like every action
movie ever it's Spider-Man trying to
save Mary Jane and a School Bus full of
children and then there are bad guys who
do bad things and what feminists would
have you believe is that what men really
fantasize about is being that villain
who wants to hurt women it's nonsense
yeah it is completely I bet a lot of the
violence of the 1900s comes from like
post-war to guys coming back from the
war and being coming alcoholic and just
a mad aggression unfocused aggression
were you about to say something
but like the idea that feminists were
the ones who came around and told us
that woman beating as bad as the most
insane nonsense right well I I can't
remember who I was talking to but they
someone was talking about how there's
like a rape culture oh yeah yeah so I
worked with somebody uh and she asked me
how many of your friends are okay with
rape and I was like what do you mean and
she was like how many of the guy friends
you know are like cool with it and I was
like zero none what are you talking
about she was like come on really yeah
and then I was like what are you kidding
do you actually think that guys in this
world are all joking and laughing about
this stuff and then she said we live in
a rape culture that promotes it I said
what are you talking about Law and Order
SVU has been on for like 20 years and
the whole premise of the show is that
it's especially heinous and we're trying
desperately to stop it well and again
they've also expanded the dash of
definition of rape and sexual assault so
so it's like the like what is sexual
assault
like that that can include like a guy
grabbing a girl's butt at a bar is that
the same thing as like what you would
think yeah
it's a salt but it's not the same and
the other and the other is still very
wrong and the other thing they don't
talk about is in Family Court family in
court is not based on evidence it is not
it is not innocent until proven guilty
it is based on a balance of
probabilities and it's again it's I
think it's a different state by state
here but I know that a lot of us like um
family courts it's the same in the UK
this is how they do it so it's basically
it's more likely you did it than you
didn't but it's not based on evidence
right so so a lot so a lot of times what
will happen and I interview these guys
is like their their entire reputation is
ruined in these communities so one these
women and the crazy thing is oh my gosh
these guys um they'll be married right
and the woman will go to the women's
shelters and at the women's shelters
like it's basically a business so
they'll tell the women what to say based
on your background so you know you're
Irish so they might say okay he's a
drunken Irish or some something like
that and the women and with one phone
call can get a restraining order around
the guy and typically he can't even like
fight like and with that one phone call
he can be kicked out of the house he
pays for he's still paying for a
mortgage on it and she can also take the
children so with one phone call she can
do that and it takes like it can take
some of the guys that took them up for
to a year to even go to court about this
and now and a year without your children
and now in the UK the other thing is
they are paid to they get a free lawyer
if they accuse a guy of sexual assault
grape or abuse in court so what will
happen is all these guys will be known
as an abuser a sexual assault like great
I don't know I don't know you can say on
here rapists in these communities and
it's like the women have all the power
they can do this with one phone call and
it's not based off of evidence have you
guys heard about what's going on with
Bam Margera no a little bit Yeah so
apparently the story is he hasn't seen
his kid in months and his argument and
his lawyers argue that it's arbitrary
that he's being denied access to his son
under some argument about the safety of
the child but he's he's he was he's
arguing like there's no risk of child at
all this is this is ridiculous she's
just keeping from my kid so he's having
a breakdown he's getting depressed he
says he cries every day and so he calls
his family and says you're keeping me
from my son and then apparently he said
this is what they reported that he said
he would smoke crack till he died if he
didn't get to see his kid so they sent
the cops after him the cops 51.50 to him
meaning they took him to him they
involuntarily institutionalized him
because like dude if you deprive a man
of his child then he becomes extremely
depressed and says let give me back my
son like they make movies about this
with Harrison Ford you know what I mean
like and said they're like lock him up I
I spoke to a guy for the documentary the
other day the wife is um treating the
kid as gender binary or gender neutral
there's nothing he can do about it yeah
she's abusing what yeah that situation
um his name's Harrison the daily wire
covered at Harrison did wait did you
donate to his cause is this in Canada I
actually think he he told me you did I
don't did I Harrison T something yeah I
probably did yeah yeah but like no it
was in California okay okay I was a
GoFundMe did I give that there's a guy
yeah James I think I think he told me
you did not younger tell us more no but
basically like his um his
ex-girlfriend was like raising the kid
as like non-binary and like he's just
spent all this money trying he still
doesn't have primary custody even though
she's literally and there's nothing he
can do about it this is not Jeffy yeah
guys you should you guys should donate
to this in the chat because he's
actually really nice he's super nice and
you can oh yeah yeah you can tell she
like loves his son I did so this is a a
Gibson go help a single father fight for
a son I gave him ten thousand dollars
and this is like this is what a father's
supposed to do right he's trying to
fight for his child right but it's so
interesting because a lot of the Trad
cons will be like oh well why don't men
just like fight for their kids and it's
like well if you saw what they have to
go through like a lot of guys go
bankrupt because again with that one
phone call she he's paying for a
mortgage that he's not even living in
like because the the house is still in
his name so he's paying a mortgage on a
house that is like he's not not he's
kicked out of because of the restraining
order then before this is before court
even happens he can be on child support
and the entire Community thinks he's an
abuser and a lot of these guys have lost
their his jobs their their jobs because
like I mean if you're all your friends
eat sometimes your family thinks you're
an abuser right like you're gonna go
kind of crazy yeah and so like a lot of
times these guys now they're unemployed
now they're in a ton of debt and there's
nothing they can do and this is when a
lot of guys zero out and they kill
themselves it's very sad and I think um
I think that is one explanation like a
lot of people they they fight until they
can't anymore like as a traditionalist
conservative I don't know that I've ever
heard anyone say that about someone who
like literally couldn't fight anymore
they did that's like a callous approach
to it well no because what they'll do is
they'll look at the stat that says like
men like the men that fight for their
kids get custody but they don't like and
so they'll say well why don't you know
what you're saying just fight for their
kids and it's like okay yeah but the
average guy doesn't have a hundred
thousand dollars to spend to get custody
of his children interesting so yeah and
the lawyers will tell them this like
because it's kind of if you're a lawyer
yeah yeah because it's it's a tough like
it's tough for guys to win unless the
mother is like there's something wrong
with her so the cases that do go to
court like typically there's something
wrong with a woman even then there was a
case with that that little boy that was
eventually killed by his mother they
gave her custody because she's the
mother okay right I don't know that was
in the United States and it was clear
that she was addicted to meth Etc and
all these things and they still gave her
custody because again like you said it's
just based on probabilities and those
probabilities in this case it was an
unusual case and like I think literally
the day or a day after they gave it back
to her she she had killed the boy so
that I I spoke there's one guy in the
documentary in the UK very similar I've
heard of many cases yeah there's a very
similar case in the UK and this guy
um he his um friends like this was the
kid who dies like best friend and the
government just took the kid they didn't
even give it back to the dad the
government just took the kid we're gonna
go to super chats but uh I will add I I
actually forgot that I I donated to that
guy but uh I saw his story and and I was
I was moved by it and I also you know
want to want to help so I donated ten
thousand dollars uh
I've also donated ten thousand dollars
to uh an activist to push back on child
sex change laws and to help fight
against it I'm saying this now because I
guess my question for everybody is I
didn't mention that I did this and I
don't know if I should or shouldn't you
know what I mean like dude don't mention
that stuff man you're The Dark Knight
Rises that's the question like with the
gift sign to go for that guy it's like
publicly you can see my name but nobody
wrote about it nobody said anything
about it with Daniel Penny it was big
news and everybody was putting my name
on top and that one I said I did but for
this uh this activist fighting against
the the child sex change stuff and for
this guy fighting for his kid I just
didn't say anything about it I just like
did it and but I'm wondering if people
think that it would be good if I did I
like I I don't want it to be like ah
look at me look how great I am but maybe
it might be like hey look there's a big
impact happening so I'm curious it's
weird to be like look how much I donated
I get that but it's good to spread
awareness for the cause itself so
sometimes it's worth you know expressing
it yeah no I think it's like if you do
it like I think it inspires other people
to do it too I think it's say something
when you do when I do I think yeah yeah
I think people know like you're a nice
guy I don't think you're trying to like
flash your money in people's you know
right well I also think too it's like
just understand we run a successful
company here and I think that the money
we make should go towards things that
are good and we put our money where our
mouth is so yeah like donated this guy
to fight for his kid I think it's
exactly what people ex people would
would want their money to be doing yeah
and a lot of the money that we get like
advertising and stuff like that and a
portion of it is memberships obviously a
lot of it's going for infrastructure and
things like that but I'm just like I
don't know I kind of feel like that's
what we should be doing with it yeah you
know I don't know and he's
tell how bad like he spent so much money
trying to get his kid and I could just
tell like how happy he was to finally
have like I think he has 50 50 custody
now but yeah yeah yeah but he yeah like
um and I I could just see how like much
so people should donate he's actually
he's really nice he's going to be in the
documentary so as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible